Paddington too is directed by Paul King
once again the same man behind the first
one and in this film young Paddington is
happily settled with the brown family
but he's looking for the perfect gift
for Aunt Lucy's birthday he goes to an
old shop and finds a beautiful pop-up
book of London and he knows Aunt Lucy
had always wanted to see London but
never got to so he thinks that giving
her this book could be the next best
thing but the book is stolen by a famous
actor named Phoenix Buchanan played by
Hugh Grant and Paddington has to try to
get himself out of a sticky situation to
get that book back I saw the first
Paddington film at home and I loved it
so much that I felt guilty I missed it
in theatres that film was so terrific it
was so charming and just so wonderful it
was one of the better family films I had
seen that year and I felt guilty for
missing it in theatres Paddington 2 is
even better this is like one of the best
movies of the year I'm not even kidding
this isn't a joke this movie is terrific
one of the things that I loved about
this film and the first but this one in
particular is how Paddington views the
world and how people treat him for his
view of the world this is a fish out of
water tale Paddington comes from a
different country he lived with two
bears and now he's in the UK with a
bunch of actual human beings and so his
view of the world is skewed oftentimes
he misinterprets conversations he
doesn't understand signals that people
give body language he has a hard time
communicating and sometimes he'll say
things that are just playing wrong
because he didn't understand something
it wasn't clear to him nobody reacts to
him like he's an idiot this film doesn't
treat him like he's stupid and the
comedy that these scenes go for does not
try to mock Paddington it doesn't look
down upon him for not understanding the
way the world works his character is
endearing it makes him adorable you
don't look at him and think wow what a
stupid character he doesn't get the way
the world is which is such a fantastic
message for young kids who watch this
movie because how many times do you see
a kid say something that's maybe more
serious than
his or her age might suggest or they say
something that just makes no sense and
everyone just starts laughing at them
and the kid feels bad like I just didn't
understand that you don't have to laugh
at me this film has a character that's
so naive so kind-hearted and likable but
it doesn't look down on him for those
qualities in fact it encourages those
qualities yes there are scenes where
Paddington has to come to a harsh
realization of what the world can really
be like and these are used to build his
character to teach him things not to
beat him down and it's just a beautiful
message and this film has a great way of
telling it it's also directed gorgeously
the shot structure here is some of the
best I've ever seen in a family film it
doesn't feel like I'm watching a movie
made for kids it's so sophisticated in
its approach to humor and in action
sequences which are actually quite
exciting I would love to see Paul King
helm a James Bond movie or an action
film like that because he clearly has a
great knack for action sequences Sally
Hawkins and Hugh Bonneville as the
parents are really great because they
also do not look down upon this material
nobody involved in this film is making
the kids film and they're getting a
paycheck everyone is really putting
forth genuine effort to be as realistic
and true to this tale as possible also
Hugh Grant is such a delight this is his
best role in years I've always been a
fan of his
he plays similar characters in similar
movies but he's great at it but he gets
to do something pretty different here he
plays this guy who is a sort of
washed-up actor who's now finding
himself in commercials for dog food but
he's world renowned for playing a
diverse amount of roles and different
accents he has all of the costumes from
various characters that he's portrayed
in his attic and he talks to them like
he's a crazy person he kind of is a
crazy person and so it's sort of a great
subversion of what we think of Hugh
Grant the actor because he portrays an
actor who views himself as washed-up who
plays a diverse amount of characters
whereas Hugh Grant in real life has been
area up front and interviews saying that
he has played one character his whole
life and he's very self aware of that
when poking the the writer said we are
considering do you think Hugh Grant
would would take the joke if we sent him
a script about a washed-up vein actor I
said trying that's a true story because
I they actually wrote the stories from
what I've read
I don't know this if it's true or not
with you in mind it actually called the
character Hugh is that true yeah they
could a Hugh Grant brendan gleeson plays
a chef I'm not gonna tell you where he
works cuz I didn't know where the plot
was going but he is so damn amazing in
this movie he is so incredibly funny
I've never seen him like this and his
play back and forth with Paddington
creates some of the best moments in the
film Paddington too surprised the hell
out of me and this is coming from
somebody who loved the first this is a
sequel that doesn't disappoint it's a
film that has an incredible message for
kids and one that adults can appreciate
especially the sophisticated humor and
it has a lot of great slapstick as well
that's not even remotely cringe-worthy
as some slapstick is in film my only
issue with the movie is maybe I would
have liked a couple more minutes at the
end and a little bit more resolution for
some characters besides that this is a
great film please don't miss this in
theaters go support it I would love to
see a third one this is one of the best
family film franchises that I've seen in
recent years I'm gonna give Paddington -
and a guys thank you so much as always
for watching my review of Maze Runner
the death cure will be out very soon you
guys are the best and as always if you
liked this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes
[Music]